join my day Joe Rogan podcast one night
all day we need a moment of silence
we're children locked up it might be the
last time we see him right yeah man
you never know I mean how many more
years can that guy go out Mount Rushmore
just bad [ __ ] yeah about 40 guys
on my mouth yeah yeah my son Mount
Rushmore has to be big as [ __ ] don't
give me four well first of all you have
to hoist Gracie
George Gracie's on Mount Rushmore period
right he was the original guy that set
it all off whether or not he still got
big numbers with that Ken Shamrock crazy
number huge numbers million Shambala on
that yeah he's got to be on it but
that's kind of like the way Babe Ruth
would be on Mount Rushmore for because
he's one of the first right so it makes
it yeah but if he ever started yeah but
yeah but Babe Ruth and always Gracie did
they did work they spent started like
they did [ __ ] right right right like
Babe Ruth's numbers are legit ashiya
always Gracie did something spectacular
is the idea that a smaller man could be
a bigger man in a real-life fight and
with techniques that you've never seen
before 16 man tournament yeah you never
see somebody saw triangles before
Eckstein boys grants he tapped out Dan
Severn no one even knew what the [ __ ] he
was doing and then when when you try to
bring it back to go like in 1998 try
going to your local jujitsu school
tell him to teach you that like well
that's advanced they were not teaching
people triangles they thought that [ __ ]
was advanced I know it dude I know it do
to went to a certain shoots in school
sitting right afterwards and they told
him you can't teach you triangles yet
you're not you know ready for that yeah
but so advanced techniques they were
holding [ __ ] back from people say doors
on that Mount Rushmore for sure a
hundred percent say doors on there and
then current guys I'd say cane how many
guys can you have on rush miles two
minutes is to Mount Rushmore go on say
you had two four four we can't have four
uniforms and silver GSP we know that
right
how did they decide we enter them selves
at JFK 100% how do they decide mmm good
question right but do you know buddy I
don't know any you know you got on who
are the guys that have stated job for a
long time you know and it's until it GSP
and Finnish dudes will you up what about
Matt Elam yeah ah finished GSP in a
title fire
how long was Matt he was on top of a
while a while the most was another real
pioneer that changed the game in a lot
of ways because he introduced the idea
that high level wrestling plus
submissions yeah like when he hit that
far side arm bar on GSP GS he went for a
Mora
and he didn't secure the legs and man
who spun around that far side arm bar
and locked it in it was beautiful
and what about your a saber what he did
feel a little done yeah and then what
and you know i favor you yeah no no but
hold on I made the problem your our
favor is you never want a UFC title and
I think if you're talking about the UID
Hall of Fame
wouldn't a pen in his primary you write
W see how my be a pen he did BJ Penn's
got to be in there yeah there before
they can't be fooled 150 people I will
have to choose yeah yeah you got a few
school dresses me up like I can't I get
stressed hold on hold on I don't want to
do it here a heavier weight in there
what heavy weight you choose it'd be
piped or Taylor or Verdana in this
argument for Purdue no I'm not for
November and O'Gara how dare you
Nogueira might be up there but no girl
might be up there you got I think fader
right over dominance for a long period
of time what about the omelet Cruz
knocking dude out amazing yeah he only
lost twice once by choke and once by
decision you know lost play so I think
long-ass time ago at 1:45 okay well John
Jones you know I'm saying like you can't
her lower you can't have a judge on
never love you like I think you're gonna
do that and cut this one guy because of
a fight Anderson Silva Conor McGregor
yeah yeah you want like some up pint
like game changes no no but I mean you
have to look at a couple things
longevity like how long were they on top
that's kind of taking place right let's
talk about criteria for it how long have
you been on top how did you did you
finish dudes that's kind of how many
finishes that that's got to play a
factor
what do you mean on write how long you
were in the top so I know how long were
you champ how long you hold the belt
that's that's got to play a factor
yeah it's a big fair how long how did
you do it did you finish how many people
did you actually finish well I got your
competition - yeah sometimes guys get
dominant and they're in a slump in the
rotation like Mike Tyson came along and
was marking everybody and it was you
know Tony Tubbs he's like hey that's the
right fight Bruce Seldon don't know like
I saw my Mount Rushmore for that reason
he's on my Mount Rushmore
got it I guess he fought everybody and
stayed on top forever and annoy
everybody boys BJ John Jones
Anderson Silva hop GSP what about the
way trade or what about mighty Mouse's
fate or not John John well see John
Jones has never lost though and he
speaks all those other guys are amazing
time how long it was the youngest champ
how long was he up on top for two years
no longer online ah Chloe beat I mean he
beat um Shogun when he was 23 mm mm-hmm
so he never lost a year at all he's 30
now you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about $7 B he wasn't on top of
seven years oh wait a minute he's on top
I'm not using
how about Josie although he's ahead of
John Jones with me yeah but he got
knocked out by karma grave robbers after
nine years yeah but there's a reality
where you got away come on based on the
overall the overall yeah he'll agree he
held the belt no he lost phenomenally
you're the big fight the big fight that
he had against his biggest library okay
okay yeah why we have so you have that
excuse yeah about Helen all that you
know that he's went to high so you went
through him like a hot knife through
butter
yeah how the old Josiah would not have
I'm dad bought boy this is what it is
mark calm Abel bay door no Anna Doppler
Coleman sketching I got mark home he
changed a lot of [ __ ] - what about line
in UFC he's doing - brought wrestlers
the problem I know what do you have seat
belt Anna pride I know true but we're
standing - Anderson on that [ __ ] that's
a good question with to have anybody
time division champion it spontaneously
never une tried us trying forced to
championship lost 95 everyone amazing
okay all you could argue that he might
have won that decision against this man
yeah anywhere other than England a lot
of people have argued that I understand
but I'm talking about people held about
you got you have to use belt holder
Spurlock with Hayden was fighting in
prides but Dan was fighting for the belt
against business Dan if he beats Bisping
and wins the middleweight title you got
a look at him is like come on yeah top
five of all time
he's still tom as far as far as the
foundry on five but who knows what the
number is that so many great about it
well these guys it's throwing hard right
away golden boy
blinders loaded right in front of this
kid
[Applause]
[Music]